I'm Patrick medieval we are here today a
special guest with us here today our
good friend the master sales trainer the
Michael Jordan Tiger Woods of sales mr.
Tom Hawkins Tom thank you for joining us
today
Patrick it's a thrill and I love hearing
all that you've done it I have a chance
to share some concepts on being an
entrepreneur you know fulfilling your
potential so I think this is excellent
what you're asking us to share with
these folks well I am looking forward
and by the way okay I was telling Tom
ten years ago I met you twelve years ago
when I came to your house and you know
you were living in somewhere in Arizona
Scottsdale right what's going through
your house we went to it I think it was
your bedroom or somewhere he had a
painting of him wrestling a lion he
happened but the neck and I said you
know one day I'm gonna have an artwork
like that we'll be wrestling an eye on a
lion and the idea came from mr. Tom out
of cancer is that love art art it's a
hobby I canceled this like this one
piece is kind of special artists do as a
kind of a talking point something to
have fun with sure sure so let's get
right into it so let's get right into it
if you don't know Tom Hopkins Tom
Hopkins wrote the number one sales book
out there called how to master your art
of selling and I read the book back in
1999 when I was first working at Bally
Total Fitness as a new salesman there
and I read the book it changed my life
on how I looked at sales so if you're an
entrepreneur you're in business you're
trying to get a promotion whatever you
trying to do sales is a part of your
business you gotta learn how sales works
tom has spoken to five million people
five million people have attended his
seminar over the years to learn sales so
we're not talking somebody that you know
just talks about sales every once in a
while he is the master of sales and he
is known as claim of fame when he was 24
years old I gotta say this 24 years old
he sold 365 homes in one year a record
that still stands 365 homes in one year
right here in our neck of the woods
that's word and in Simi Valley and even
out yeah senior valiant and calm I asked
a personal question from Tom I said Tom
let me ask you who were you in high
school right and he didn't want to say
that first say who were you in high
school he says well you know I was the
captain of the football team quarterback
four years you said which high school
alum Alemany high Alemany how we have a
lot of people that want Alemany high so
let's get right into it I got some some
very straightforward questions that I
want the guys to get value here
everybody that's watching first question
you've trained millions of people you've
seen all the mistakes you've seen all
the right thing that works what is the
number one secret to why a Salesman
makes it in sales number one secret well
the first thing is they work harder on
themselves they do on the job to become
a person that relates to more people if
I had you in an elevator for ten floors
and you said as you just said what's the
secret I would say develop a personality
and a temperament and a way of coming
across with people where they really do
like you and trust you and then they
want one listen to you and when I first
started practicing this I started
realizing that people want a
relationship they selling is a very
important part of life and especially in
our country of capitalism and free
enterprise but it's also something that
you can learn but it starts with working
on yourself to be a person that again
people relax with that are they're
comfortable with where they feel like
I'm confident this person can help me
have a better life be more successful
achieve my goals and that of course is
how I live my life today try to help
this happen with as many people would
like to hear my message
interesting so you're number one to be
good in sales not necessarily to make a
lot of money so because that's a whole
different answer but to be good in sales
it's relatability no one how to relate
to somebody else in different situations
unbelievable okay what would you say is
the number one mistake there's a lot of
mistakes we make our salespeople what is
number one mistake a Salesman makes I
think the number one mistake that
salesperson makes is coming across like
a stereotypical salesperson see the
average American in our studies doesn't
really like selling they don't really
feel good about sales people and to
shame that's true but of the 11 million
salespeople approximately in the United
States many of them turn people off
because they come across a little bit
too aggressive they come across almost
pushy and they're talkative I've tried
to teach people be the opposite of what
they expect and they'll relax with you
become a master questioner and I have a
little goal become a master asker at a
magnificent listener and you'll do well
in the field of sales regardless of it
and I've had a battle Patrick to that I
believe everybody in a way is in sales I
think if you're a parent and your kids
grow up to be good adults thanks to your
example your questioning your listening
skills that you did make a good sale
with your children I think in today's
world if you stay married for your
entire life you both husband and wife
did some of the things I teach that are
part of the art of selling so I hope
people will open their minds to as an
entrepreneur you're selling the people
that work for you to do a better job
you're teaching them the art of
persuasion of convincing folks to do
business with your company not once but
for a lifetime so this is again
something I think that is so true that
everyone in a way is in in sales very
cool
ok so third one what was your edge
against your competitors I think my
hedge was I really did outwork most
people I was fanatical on wanting to
achieve
when I quit college after 90 days and I
only have been made it for three months
I was terrified I didn't know what I was
going to do and fortunately after one
year of construction carrying steel I
found the real estate business and in a
way I found my niche and I hope
everybody that's maybe viewing this
program will find their niche in life
and I call the niche finding something
you love to do that is not work but you
love it so much you're great at it and
then you develop the p-word
which I learned this wayne gretzky act
like golf of Wayne and as you know he
probably weren't the greatest hockey
players of all times and after the game
I driving to the house I said I gotta
ask you a what do you reason was you did
so well
as a hockey player and he gave me the
p-word he said Tom I had a passion for
all aspects of the sport passion for
practice passion for winning passion for
losing and so that that's the day I said
I'm going to try to teach people to get
passionate about what they do not just
like it but be passionate because I
think people will agree and go along
with your way of thinking based more on
your belief your conviction and your
passion than almost anything else so you
would say your edgewood's passion
passion okay I love I love real estate I
will work seven days a week my first
three days our first three years a lot
of people don't want to do that seven
days a week of seven days I had three
Christmas days off which is fanatical
and I'm not saying that's right for
everyone but I hear that's a that's a
very consistent that rate with a lot of
people that make it to the highest level
of whatever they do and that word you
just said I don't know if you caught up
a consistency is one of the keys to much
success in your life where you don't
just have high cycles low cycles you're
consistent and of course I also feel
that I I was a follow-up specialist with
people I kept in touch I've built
long-term relationships my last year
that
number of sales most of them were
referred to me because I did a good job
with people and I think that it's a
people business regardless of what
business you're in I think you are all
all of us in the people business and the
way you handle people the way you do
business with people well at the end of
the line decide how successful you
become okay so time the last question
here before we wrap up you know there's
a lot of people you meet that are afraid
of getting into sales there's a lot of
people you meet that are a question and
say I don't think I could do it I don't
think my personal but I don't think I
could ever go into self do you believe
anybody could make it in sales well I
have had this as a challenge all of my
training career is to convince people
that I think anybody can learn the art
of selling as long as they realize a
couple points and let me illustrate it
this way that there are two extremes to
a temperament or a personality of a
person we'll call this person over here
the interesting extrovert then we'll
call this person the interested
introvert now if you listen to those
titles interesting versus interested the
average person that thinks they would be
great in sales and people tell them they
would are the interesting extroverts
there over the Bering a little bit
they're talkative
they love to control conversations they
aren't real good listeners they can do
well in sales the interested introvert
is somewhat humble somewhat shy a little
afraid of maybe strangers maybe really a
fear full of rejection this person can
do extremely well and what I try to get
people to do is if you're an interesting
extrovert try to move more towards the
middle being more like an interested
introvert if you're an interested
introvert move a little bit towards the
middle to be more like an interesting
extrovert because the ideal personality
that establishes relationships and does
a great job in communication can move to
the interesting extrovert
or to the interesting
introvert and the ability to relate to
other people and have them feel good
because of the way you come across the
way you are with them that to me can be
taught and learned by anyone
and so I really feel it yes if you would
be willing to let me be your mentor and
your teacher I think I could teach
anybody to be an effective salesperson
and some of them to achieve a high
degree of accomplishment on I decided
offend along either side is that not
interesting okay so Tom to wrap it thank
you so much by the way for coming in
today
my pleasure and allowing us to do this
interview with you we talked about the
book earlier how to master the art of
selling but you have a new book out yeah
it's called when buyers say no what
could you say to us about this book
because I really like the title one
buyer said no we do you know it's
flooding magic is this darden book it's
my 18th book and when I wrote it thanks
to Ben Codd who's my co-author we came
up with the concept that most people
don't realize that you'll not even get a
yes in life of anything until you
usually have some type of no and so
really selling as an art form starts
with the no and so I thought we're going
to go ahead and take exactly what an O
means what they're really saying behind
the word no what are they really meaning
and then what we decided to do is take
been caught fabulous circle of
persuasion concept and took that and
combined my training on questioning a
listening on turning a no into a yes and
we combined it and I'm not being
braggadocious but this book so far in
the first six months is out sold any
book I've written in the first six
months no yes and I think the reason is
people want to know that hey I want to
handle the word no to turn into the
yeses with my kids with my spouse with
the people that work for me I think
employers with their employees
can really benefit from the circle of
persuasion and the concept of when
buyers say no I saw a circular
persuasion in there at the end what
could you tell us about that what is
circular Forster probably what it is
basically been decided to take the word
No
then we took and show all the little
steps that we go through in the
persuasion process of gradually taking
that know and through the right little
questions of minor yeses ending up
getting the big yes which is a agreement
to go along with whatever you're
suggesting they do be an invest in a
product being the child doing what
you're asking them to do being an
employee getting up doing better better
job so it's really exciting to see that
most people in business want to know how
do I handle d'Arnaud and turn them into
yeses that that is the question it's the
question of the skill to learn so uh
where you could get this book as we've
attached a link on the bottom of
description if you click on the link
it'll take you to the place on Amazon to
be able to buy this book when buyers say
no if you haven't read it get a copy of
it Tom thanks so much for coming out
really appreciate you your Pat and what
can everybody find you out there by the
way there is their Twitter is their
Facebook at their website I just go to
Tom Hopkins comm and they'll have all of
our products all of our seminars and
what are they if they're looking for
more of what we do they can sure find us
there and by the way if you want to go
to seminar we're hosting an event with
Tom Hopkins in Las Vegas and we're very
excited about it'll be at the real Las
Vegas we're putting the event together
if you want to know more information
about I send us information it's
normally a full and $1.00 event that he
does but since we're putting it together
it's going to be $200 cost for anybody
that wants to attend that convention
send me information we'll send you more
and more about that event aside from
that Tom Hopkins thanks for joining us
we'll see you guys on our next episode
take care thank you
you